and the Los Angeles Times has new
guidelines for prostate cancer screening
the US Preventive Services Task Force
says men between the ages of 55 and 69
should talk to their doctors about
getting the blood test that looks for
markers of the disease the test is not
recommended for men 70 and older the
panel had previously advised against
routine screening our dr. David agus
heads the University of Southern
California's website
excuse me Westside Cancer Center good
morning doctor I was already confused by
all of this which I said website and
sign can you break this down for us I'm
gonna try so 29,000 people a year die of
prostate cancer the second most common
cancer a cause of death in men and
there's a test a blood test called the
PSA test where it's elevated can
indicate prostate cancer but could also
be inflammation or just a normal large
prostate so in the United States they
did a trial where they said to people
you get tested and you do whatever you
want and it didn't show a survival
advantage because to do whatever you
want arm they got tested anyway in
Europe they did this study and what they
showed is that people lived longer
in 2012 the our government
recommendation the US Preventive task
force said people shouldn't get tested
because there's not a major survival
advantage but what is shown in that
trial as it's gone longer as more and
more people were saved that being said
it's not a perfect test but age 55 down
to 69 you should have a discussion with
your doctor they're not saying go get it
but they're saying it's a value systems
based decision and it really requires a
talk with your doctor what am I going to
get in that talk though that's gonna
make this less confusing to me well it's
going to say that when you have this or
chances of false positives which means
that it can be elevated for a reason not
because of cancer and then if there's a
biopsy not all prostate cancers actually
need to be treated and if we do treat
the cancer there's side effects to
treatment so it's really understanding
the ramifications of making a decision
that being said listen I am tested I
believe in it I see all the morbidity of
cancer and people dying of cancer and
I'll do anything I can to prevent it and
I haven't discussed within my patients
most of my patients want the test so
what what is the panel
commend that you don't get it over the
age of 70 you touched on it briefly
well they look at you know they say
people with less than 10 to 15 years of
survival which in classically the 870
they shouldn't have the test because
there's a delay between the diagnosis of
cancer and a winner will cause symptoms
and potentially death and so you know if
you're very healthy at 70 you probably
should have it although the panel
doesn't say that what puts an average
man at risk higher risk for prostate
cancer so african-americans people with
a family history and people with certain
genetic disorders have a much higher
risk of prostate cancer and the
screening discussion in them is
different you know that being said there
are newer technologies now you could
have an MRI first and then MRI of the
prostate can actually look and visualize
some of the cancers and guide the
biopsies and reduce false positives so
the tests are getting better also all
right dr. agus thanks very much